et comment s'est déroulée l'audience
aujourd'hui quel impact aura le procès
sur la formation d'un gouvernement un
élément de réponse avec paula slayer
journalistes pour rt internationale cela
fait maintenant plus d'un an que de
telles accusations sont échangés selon
le premier ministre benyamin nétanyahou
ses détracteurs mène une chasse aux
sorcières voir un push il dit que ses
accusateurs tente de l'écarter du
pouvoir
dans le même temps pour les opposants de
benyamin nétanyahou il est en train de
mener une sorte de coup d'état du
gouvernemental contre les accusations
auxquelles il est confronté
benyamin nétanyahou est serré de
délégitimer le résultat du procès et
voudrait avoir une forme de pouvoir
absolu sur les cas d'israël
certains craignent qu'il ne puisse pas
se concentrer sur la gestion du pays une
fois pris par le procès et que réélu
premier ministre il pourrait trouver un
moyen de stopper la procédure judiciaire
cette affaire pourrait également salir
la réputation du système judiciaire il
serait aujourd'hui l'ex pdg de vale à un
média israélien a témoigné selon lui le
premier ministre mettait une telle
pression sur va là qu'il avait reçu le
sobriquet de kim jong-il et cette
pression pour recevoir une couverture
médiatique positive l'a aidé ou les
élections et dans l'opinion publique
puis il devrait y avoir d'autres
témoignages similaires dans la suite du
procès dans les jours à venir les
consultations permettent d'établir qui
est en mesure de former un gouvernement
de coalition
un parti doit remporter 61 sièges sur
les 120 de la knesset c'est à dire le
parlement les consultations entre les
différents partis n'ont commencé malgré
le procès de benyamin nétanyahou
certains partis notamment à droite du
spectre politique chasse par exemple où
le parti likoud benyamin nétanyahou
l'ont déjà recommandé pour être le
prochain premier ministre
mais tenir il est très peu probable que
le procès influence l'issue de ces
consultations il y à déjà plus d'un an
la cour suprême d'israël a déclaré que
le procès n'avait pas de conséquence sur
le gouvernement à venir et les
consultations
cette déclaration de la cour suprême
aura toujours du poids aujourd'hui cela
n'aura pas d'effet sur les consultations
et pour être franche les partis ne se
préoccupe pas vraiment des procès les
opposant à des gamines netanyahu a
essayé de le tourner à leur avantage et
les partisans de benyamin nétanyahou
font exactement la même chose
les cela ne va pas vraiment influencé le
résultat des consultations il semble
très improbable que benyamin nétanyahou
réussir à former un gouvernement
le président israélien reuven rivlin a
rencontré aujourd'hui les différents
partis politiques ce qui est la coutume
en israël il rencontre les différents
partis et leurs demandes qu'il
recommande comme premier ministre il a
lancé le processus et rien n'est arrivé
selon la constitution israélienne il
n'est pas obligatoire de demander aux
parties qui a fait le plus de voix mais
est recommandé de demander aux parties
le plus susceptible de former un
gouvernement de coalition
à ce stade il semble que ce parti sera
celui de benyamin nétanyahou il devrait
donc proposer à benyamin nétanyahou de
tenter le premier de former un
gouvernement de coalition change